In the previous video,
we introduced Hoeffding's inequality, which puts a probability bound on
the amount by which our estimate of beta will deviate from the actual value.
We saw that this bound is actually a function of
the number of data points that we have.
So, let's try to apply that to our own problem, and
try to find a confidence bound for our beta parameter.
Recall that the beta value that came out of our exponential fit
was 1451.5 seconds.
Let's used Hoeffding's inequality to put a 95% confidence
interval around this value.
So, first let's recall the number of data points we have is approximately 3200.
So, what we want is for the right side of this expression to equal 5% or 0.05.
So specifically, if you solve this expression here for
Absalom, you get a value of about 0.0240.
Now, what does this mean exactly?
That means,
this interval traps the true value of data with a probability of 95%.
So, if we're going to use this exponential to predict the amount of
time to wait until this person Tweets next,
the best that we can say is that it lies somewhere within this interval